So there are several correct ways you could have
answered this question and what I've done is given you
four different levels of answers that could have fit.
And they're all sort of ranked in order of being
an OK answer to really what would be the
most comprehensive and best answer based on the material that
you've been presented with here. So I want to read them
to you and see what you think. an okay answer
would have just said the human genome is made of
DNA, right. And you just sort of remember one, you know,
very important point but, you know, didn't say anything else. A
good answer would have said that the human genome is 23
pairs of nuclear chromosomes, right. We know that they're in the
nucelus, and we know that we also have a mitochondrial chromosome
and that They're all made of DNA. A better answer would
have said that we have to copies of over 3 billion
base pairs of DNA, and it's organized into
23 pairs of chromosomes. And we have the
nuclear genome, and then we have the mitochondrial
genome. The best possible answer would've said that we've
got two copies of over three billion base
pairs of DNA. To organize by histone proteins into
23 pairs of linear chromosomes, 22 are autosomes,
and we have a single pair of sex chromosomes.
That's in the nuclear genome. And we have one
copy from each parent. And then of course we
have 17,000 basepairs From a circular mitochondrial chromosome found
in every mitochondrion, we have many per cell. So
this would be the most comprehensive or exhaustive answer.
Okay, what I want you to do is to
actually look back at the answer, your response for
this question. And see how it compares to the
four you see here. And then I want you to rank
your response here on the left. So, if you rank right here
with this first answer, I want you to check the box
that says OK. If you're think you're somewhere in between these two
answers, the first and the second, then you can check the
box in between them. If you think your answer is more similar
to the second one then click the box for good. And
I want you to look at each of these and think about
where your answer, your response best fits,
and then check the box that's most appropriate.